Exactly a year ago at San
Francisco we introduced a new
division in Microsoft called
Microsoft AI Research.
We actually have the mission
to democratize AI for everyone.
It has been a very
exciting year in 2017.
We expected and delivered.
A very exciting year.
So I'm here to share some
of the progress with you.
I appreciate this
opportunity to show you,
especially, some
very practical ways
that AI is helping everyone
to improve our lives.
So everyone is talking
about AI nowadays.
But AI is really not new.
AI was really something, really
the ultimate goal that for
brilliant minds,
people like Alan Turing,
those people imagined that
some day, if we have this
unbelievable computing power,
what could we really do.
The first thing that Alan Turing
really imagined was doing AI
is really mimicking
human intelligence.
And at Microsoft, our very own
Bill Gates, when he created
the Microsoft Research 26 years
ago, he imagined that someday,
computers could see, hear, talk,
and understand the human beings.
That's really generalized AI.
And the AI is now happening
fast, why is that?
To me it's really three forces
that are converging to make
these things happen.
It's really the big data, more
and more aware with the web,
with IoT and everything.
And massive computing power,
especially with the cloud.
But most recently especially
with breakthrough algorithms
like deep learning or deep
neural nets that really moved
the AI from the labs
to the mainstream.
So today we are going to talk
to you about every day AI.
It's really the AI is available
to everyone, everywhere,
and then whatever you do in your
personal and professional life.
So how AI's going to help.
But in many ways,
if you just read articles in
the general press, AI probably
has gotten a bad reputation,
because much of the AI
discussions about humans versus
machines but
not enough about AI potentials.
We know AI will transform
every business and
help every life to potentially
solve some of those
societal challenges
that we all face.
You might ask that,
that all sounds great, but
what about Microsoft AI,
what's so
unique about what we do
at Microsoft about AI?
Well we believe that AI comes
down to one thing, people.
AI will amplify human ingenuity,
making people the heroes.
And then driving a healthy
connection between humans and
the machines.
That's what we
believe at Microsoft.
After all, that's really
about the Microsoft mission.
That is,
empower every person and
every organization on
the planet to achieve more.
Now I will even add, with AI.
It's really a powerful mission.
And not too long ago, our CEO,
Satya Nadella shared
our world view.
That is the intelligent
cloud and
the intelligent
edge infused by AI.
In a way, it's really about
ubiquitous computing and
ambient intelligence finally
happening, with PCs, phones, and
then more and more IOT devices.
Just imagine that you
walk into any room, you
know you walk to a speaker, you
walk to a screen, or you don't
even realize that those things
happening, existing in the room.
Then you can already, you know,
talk to Cortana,
to get things done.
Maybe across the room with the
help of far field cameras and
far field speakers.
So our goal is really to help
everyone, everywhere and
take advantage of AI every day.
So that's exactly why Satya and
I actually created it,
our AI in the research division.
And a little over a year ago.
It has been a really
exciting year.
And with more than 8,000
researchers and engineers
working together very closely
and we're making great progress.
And in particular,
we leveraged the talent and
the technology coming out of
our Microsoft Research labs.
By accelerating the cycle
from research to the product.
And take a quick look at the
video about some exciting things
we have been doing last year.
Actually how we even help
people without voices,
how they can
communicate using AI.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
clearly I could've used
some help over here too.
Yeah.
>> In the middle of our
products and into the hands.
[MUSIC]
It's great to see ideas and
technologies.
That have come smack in
the middle of our products, and
into the hands of our users.
>> You have lunch with Tony at
CJs, from 12:30 to 1:30 PM.
>> It's changing the way
that we work with the land.
And it's changing the way
the land works for us.
[MUSIC]
>> Top and
left edges not visible.
Hold steady.
Lease agreement.
[MUSIC]
Hey, Cortana?
>> What's my schedule today?
>> [MUSIC]
AI is gonna change
everyday life.
Our goal is that we make
it a lot better for people.
[MUSIC]
>> Well this is of course
just a small sample of so
many things happening
in Microsoft AI and R.
And I want to explain to you
those areas that we actually
make investment.
There are really five things
that we do in Microsoft AI and
R, and we started with
Microsoft research with a lot
of groundbreaking AI
technologies there.
Then we built a lot of AI
products, products like Bing and
the Cortana,
helping you with every day life.
And we are infusing AI into
all Microsoft products.
You know with Windows and
Office and the many others.
And we have built AI platforms,
it's really truly a cloud and
AI platform that we can help
Microsoft developers and
their partners to build
their AI applications.
And we also see incredible
opportunities there with
AI solutions.
Practically every vertical
industry is going to be
disrupted, whether it's
healthcare or transportation.
And every horizontal
business processes
whether it's marketing,
sales, or customer support.
And it will be disrupted by AI.
So we see incredible
opportunities there.
But let me first of all
show you a few highlights,
the coolest technology we
have developed from MSR,
Microsoft Research Unit,
getting in to the real products.
The first example I want to talk
to you is on speech recognition.
Just a few months ago we
announced that we, for the first
time ever now we actually have
the speech recognition system
that match in a human parity
in terms of error rate.
There has been this standard
data set in the United States
called the switchboard data set.
That was initially set up
by DARPA 25 years ago.
So the human error
rate was about 5.1%.
I'm not even talking
about ordinary humans,
I'm talking about the
professionals who do transcript.
In ways that deepen your with
massive competing power and
with brilliance of our
researchers who finally reached
in the human parity in the 5.1%.
In the second area I want to
talk to you is actually machine
reading comprehension or
natural language understanding.
Last year we acquired
this Montreal-based Deep
learning company
called the Maluuba.
They do amazing work in
the reading and the writing and
the machine reading
comprehension.
You will see more and more
Maluuba technologies get into
Microsoft products, in Office,
in Bing and other places.
The third area is actually
a machine translation.
So we have been doing machine
translation for a long,
long time in our research labs.
But now you can get machine
translation in many,
many products.
A few year ago,
we shipped the machine
translation in Skype Translator.
Last year, we actually shipped
the Microsoft translator in iOS
and other mobile apps.
And just a month ago it was
a great partnership with Huawei.
Now, we're actually
shipping machine translator
in those Huawei's flagship
phones, like Mate 10.
And clearly,
with all those comparison data,
we see that we now have the most
accurate machine translator on
any mobile phones, today
actually with Huawei's Mate 10.
So those are the really exciting
things in research with
technology, and we're moving
to mainstream products.
And that I want to talk about
the AI platform as well,
just imagine what it
would be like that if
all of the developers could use
all those cool technologies that
we have in Microsoft and
from our labs.
What if we actually
make them available,
especially through
our cloud platform.
So we actually have one
of the most comprehensive
cloud plus AI platforms
on the market.
You know there
are really three pieces
that I want you to understand
that we talk about AI platform,
these are the services
that we can offer.
And there is the infrastructure
as AI on data and AI computes.
And there is also tools like
the Visual Studio tools,
Visual Studio in the tools for
AI that we recently shipped.
And there's limited time today,
I'm going to just a deep dive
into some services that
are already shipped.
So first of all,
I'd like to share with you
that more than 760,000
developers are already using
Microsoft Cognitive Services.
And this is agreed set
of web APIs, developers
can just take them and weave
into their own applications.
And it's really great to see
the mix of the customers,
like Molson Coors and
UPS, Aurora Health Care,
how they have been using
Microsoft's cognitive services.
And we really want to
help every developer
become an AI developer.
It's not only just our partners.
At Microsoft we use
cognitive services too
to create unique
user experiences.
One of my favorite is this
little app called seeing AI.
We actually launched it in July.
It's an app using computer
vision AI technology
to help the blind and
the visually impaired.
And it's amazing to see that
more than 100,000 downloads
already happened.
And it has a rating of 4.8.
It's really very touching to me
how we can actually create apps
that people really depend on.
And there is a great
response from the community.
And today where we release even
more greater features, for
Seeing AI App.
Such as Currency Recognition and
Color Recognition, and
Light Detection.
I will encourage you to take
time after this, and stop by
the booth and check out and
you will learn in the great user
design questions there how you
can even take those technology.
How the people who couldn't
really see very well.
It makes you think about
the design very differently,
like using different
modalities to help.
So this is just one example.
The other thing we feel very,
very good about.
That we know, it is really
helpful to the developers.
Is that amount of all
those 30 API's that we've
already shipped.
One of them is called the
Language Understanding Service
is called the LUIS.
That is really, really,
getting, very, very, popular.
And the customers like it
Dixons Carphone, Sabre, and
Human Interact.
And we really appreciate the
help, giving us their feedback,
and helped us to get the product
to a certain quality.
Today I'm very happy to
announce the LUIS now is GA,
is generally available.
So it's very, very exciting.
And anther thing, and I want
to talk about today helping
the developers is actually
Azure Bot Services.
In many, many companies,
companies like Progressive,
Unilever, Publicis,
they want to build the bots and
the apps to interact with the
customers, with the employees.
Much like we talk to each other.
Just like humans.
And that we offered
Azure Bot Service not only help
you to create the bots, but also
help you to deploy the bots, and
also help you to run your bots.
And we already have
248,000 developers using
Azure Bots Services even
in the previous formats.
But today, we are announcing
that it's GA now.
So it's very exciting.
And of course, we realize that
as we develop a AI, we really
have to drive the connection
with the AI community.
And to democratize AI
is not just the one
company's responsibility,
it's really the whole
community's responsibility.
I'll give you a few examples
here of what we've been doing at
Microsoft.
The first example is this
intermediate representation,
this thing called Onnx.
It's called an open neural
network exchange project
that we started with
Facebook in September.
It's really an open source
format that enables those
AI frameworks to interoperate
with each other.
So this is example number one.
The second example is actually
what we have been doing
with Amazon.
it's called the Gluon.
So Gluon is the AI
framework interface.
There are so many AI
frameworks out there, and
we don't want these
developers to be confused.
They can choose any
of the framework and
they can get help
from Amazon and
Microsoft to start with
something called Gluon to bypass
all those complexities without
sacrificing any of the speed.
And the third example I want to
share with you is that we have
been making a lot of investments
with Microsoft venture.
In those leading AI companies,
emerging companies,
there's some good examples I
showed here like Element.AI, and
Bonsai, and Tact.
So those are very exciting
activities that we do.
And another thing I wanted to
share with you is that we see
those vertical solutions and
very, very exciting.
And especially one example, we
actually really pushed hard at
Microsoft together
with our partners.
That is, the business AI
solutions for customer services.
And I'm sure at some
point of your life,
you used customer services and
typically,
you use customer services,
you spend a lot of time.
In the end, you still get
frustrated This is where AI can
really come into help.
The system what can you imagine
is that actually you can have
a virtual agent.
And you have an agent
assistants, and the conversation
management tool to bring
all those things together.
We have great partners
like HP and Macy's and
the Australia government,
Department of Human Services.
Already working with us to
deliver those fantastic
solutions.
So those are really exciting
things that we have been doing
in Microsoft AI and are.
But today I want you
focused on every day AI.
I want you to talk about what
are those practical ways.
What are those products that
we are already shipping.
With new and cool AI features to
really help everyone, every day.
So let me start with one
of those most pervasive
forms of AI,
is called the search.
And you might say, so
what's new in search?
I have been using search for
a long, long time and
I would argue that
searches really moved on.
It's no longer just cabra links.
Now, in search can be so
powerful with the concepts and
there was dialogs with
many more things.
In the Microsoft,
we have viewed the Bing really
beyond just a search engine.
Bing has helped to build
the Microsoft Cloud Services
with all those back
end infrastructure.
And Bing has become
the foundation for AI for
our company.
And Bing might be just
much bigger than you
even think about.
And we actually launched
the Bing in year 2007.
And is now powering
over a third of
the PC web search traffic
in the United States and
continues to grow in the US and
worldwide.
And it also powers some search
experiences from many of
our partners including Yahoo.
Now it's Verizon, AOL, and
Amazon, and the multilingual
ability of Twitter, and
Apple's image search.
Of course in the source search
we have developed some really
foundational AI technologies
especially in natural language
understanding.
So this is really, a lot
of things that we can depend
on the future AI development.
So today I'm very very excited
to introduce three new
intelligence search capabilities
that we shipping immediately
with Bing.
The first thing is what we
called Intelligent Answers.
So that utilizes machine
reading company henching.
To present you with multiple
perspectives share snippets of
multiple answers, verify answers
across multiple sources and
translates data into easy
to understand concepts.
So it's not only you see more of
the model's answers popping up.
The pop of research is out
of the page from Bing,
but you will get a lot
more perspective as well.
Second, Intelligent
Image Search,
that enables you to search
image within the images,
that by leveraging
object recognition.
So that's another cool
way to find what you're
really looking for.
The third new feature about the
new intelligent research in Bing
is what I call
the conversational search.
That really provides
the encouraging suggesting
to help you to find what
your really looking for.
Very often we understand
that we want to search for
something, but
it's really hard to express.
What if we actually turn that
experience into more a dialogue?
So that's the third thing
called Conversational Search.